every year grandkids cousins
pretty much everyone gets together even
grandma I tell her pretty much
everything like this I mean that's what
I thought you said the animals winters
has begun it's the one night of the year
our ancestors can come visit us I
thought I might've been one of those
made-up things time tonight is about
family
I am not like the rest of my family
there's something that makes me
different great-great-grandfather I want
to be a musician just like you all right
moving uh I'm sorry
welcome to the land of your ancestors oh
yeah we're your family
your skeletons your eyes
[Music]
gotta get home before sunrise or you'll
be forever oh it's so time you my boy
are meant to be a musician I must follow
my heart I am trying to save your life
nice kitty
again something's not good more than you
think
sorry
may have our differences but nothing's
more important than family
[Music]
oh wait you go it's just painting never
named a street dog they'll follow you
forever
now go get my shoe
you